the sun rises over the cordillera blanca
mountains high in the peruvian andes
these mountains are home to huge
glaciers that provide water for farming
and drinking to millions across northern
peru but they're literally melting away
at an astonishing rate one third have
gone in just 10 years
72 percent of the world's tropical
glaciers are here
they exist around the equator at
altitudes above four thousand meters but
because of their position on the equator
they are particularly sensitive to
climate change
as the world warms the glaciers retreat
you used to be able to drive to the
places in peru to see them now you have
to walk
charlie good has been here for 17 years
he took us to the janapacha glacier at
just under 5000 meters
the changes to the mountains and its
glaciers because of global warming are
he says all too obvious to see
you can see that massive rock slab which
is now exposed when i was here
17 years ago or maybe even 15 years ago
that has receded all the way back so a
couple hundred meters
um and when i was actually up here in
november a couple of years ago we had
about no there's maybe one waterfall
coming off that glacier in november when
the sun's almost directly overhead
tropical there were nine waterfalls
coming off there that means it's
absolutely brilliant i mean it's it's
just it's melting before your eyes i
mean it's i was crying i was filming a
clip and just crying about how much
water is coming off that glacier
the melting waters from the glaciers
fill huge lakes that in turn provide
water further downstream
too much water and they flood and the
water is lost
climate change and increasing
temperatures hit this part of the world
in the 1970s
glaciers started melting that wasn't a
disaster because huge amounts of water
was released went down the valleys and
went eventually all the way to the
deserts near the coast where there was a
farming bonanza because of the huge
amount of water that was created the
problem is that water and agriculture
was dependent upon these glaciers but
they are melting at an incredible rate
very soon perhaps in the next two
decades there won't be any water and
those farms will all be in desert once
again
across northern peru the glacial waters
are directed into vast farms it's
produce exported worldwide
these are strawberries grown on the side
of the mountain
experts say that increasingly erratic
climate conditions and the drop in
glacier water is threatening these farms
existence
the water that comes
one of the world's leading authorities
on this is cesar porta carrero he's been
warning peru and the world about the
effects of climate change for two
decades
now he says we're on the edge of
disaster
we have to think in the new generation
nothing
we are going to leave this nice world in
some time
in the near future
but we are leaving the problem as james
hansen say storms for our grandchildren
we are leaving the problem for them
and if we love them we should work
things now
lima is one of the world's driest
capitals it barely rains
without the precious glacial water that
is directed to the centre of town it
would all look like this
a desert with people struggling to live
even the people on the edge of town
depend on water channeled to them from
the glaciers
without the glaciers there is no life
stuart ramsey sky news peru